[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys
what's going on happy tuesday
okay today's had to think about it a
little bit
the descent yeah descent a 21st century
horror classic yeah 2005.
this is a great [ __ ] movie yeah i saw
some [ __ ] in this movie that jenny
didn't notice she says oh yeah maybe
well that would give it a double meeting
when they go down and say
about these girls they end up going in
this cave
all right these are um british and
scottish and
irish girl i think one american girl
they're all
coming from the honky motherland they
come here to appalachia
even though that's not where it was shot
but then yeah they you know they come to
appalachia and they
they decide to go down into this cave
all right and they get lost down in
there it's a bad idea spoiler alert
that [ __ ] happens
i guess think they get dirty and uh
tom likes that yeah and they find some
damn monsters living in there
they're cavemen they're blind and [ __ ]
they use echolocation
like a bat they also have kind of a bat
sort of nose and back
kind of ears yeah they kind of guess
they evolved to be kind of like
bats but they on their way down there
noticed something they showed that
they showed a damn painting of like a
crowmanian painting yeah
of a bunch of buffalo
big mountain and then two entrances into
the mountains
and they're like oh there must be
another way out and uh
i was like uh what were the cavemen
doing that what were neanderthal doing
down there
and i realized that those monsters were
the neanderthals
they were maybe it was another branch
like me because maybe some
because they don't like really explain
that in the movie yeah
and so you could totally like come to
the conclusion
yeah that the monsters that are in the
cave because there are monsters in the
cave
again spoiler alert right um yeah that
maybe there were
like maybe the neanderthals didn't turn
into that but maybe like some
neanderthals were kind of like
you know it was like a branch of them
that's just like we're going to stay in
the cave they call them neanderthals
they weren't natives all by the painting
they were chrome
yeah they're crowmanians so we're given
the idea possibly i'm going way ahead
all right because you know i know you
guys most of you guys have seen this
movie so i mean i would hope so this is
a great
[ __ ] movie i love this movie i
realized that
cro-magnon were down in that cave and
evidently some of them stayed and
survived and lived on as these
things nice and warm in here yeah well
we can get out
that means that not only are they
descending into the cave the monsters
have descended
they're the descendants of the of the
[ __ ] descent also
they're the descendants of the crow man
well and also the
the title also has a third meaning yeah
because there are some interpretations
that the main character sarah
also represents her descent into madness
okay all right so there you go three
[ __ ] meetings right
in one [ __ ] title that's pretty
[ __ ] good
yeah that's they all descended from one
another
yeah so so yeah so in case you guys have
not seen the descent okay now i'm going
to warn you the version that's on amazon
prime
because that's weird because you have it
on blu-ray but it doesn't work on some
of our blu-ray players they said time
goes better
yeah [ __ ] right i went better but see
i like that idea though i like that idea
that that was kind of well actually
because you said well
or they evolved from the cavemen and i
said oh that wouldn't be that would mean
like oh
like descent though yeah you know i
don't know if that was intentional but
yeah it would totally
because they don't meaning yeah it's
like what neanderthal didn't or not
but crowman did go into caves yeah
aztecs went down there to do offerings
to the gods
in the underworld and i was like
what does it have to do with these
monsters did they see the monsters too
and i went no wait
hold on that's that's them yeah that's
the
that's i mean that's kind of what i
always thought because i've seen this
movie like a bunch of times because they
were eating
the same food yeah they could get to the
surface
because because there was some
foreshadowing uh
you know before they even go into the
cave system uh there's like a dead
was it a moose like a caribou or a
caribou
or something like that um yeah so there
was like some i couldn't really tell
what it was but so it was one and there
was like kind of bite marks taken out of
it
so you're led to believe that these
creatures can
get out and like and they just drag the
food back well they behave with them
they had carcasses down in there yeah
there was a [ __ ] ton of deer and
and and all different animals like dogs
and [ __ ] so they were going up to the
surface of hunting
but they had sidestepped extinction
by uh living down in that damn caves
like troglodytes yeah
cavemen literally cavemen men down in
them caves
see
[Laughter]
well that's kind of the cool thing about
the monsters in this is that they are
believable monsters they because they
kind of look like people but they're
you know they're all pale they've gone
blind you know like some cave fish have
done
something and they and they hunt by echo
location like a bat does
yeah which like i said that seems kind
of plausible
at least for a movie that somebody that
it would you would evolve in that
direction if you
just lived in that environment all the
time sure yeah but if they were coming
up to eat
because they had to go up to eat to eat
the animals there would have been no
reason for them to go blind over time
well see that's the one that's the one
flaw but like i said in the movie
um it's you know that's it's totally
plausible it's way more scientific than
like some other
[ __ ] i've seen in movies they should
have left them like the vandal in
um in uh eaters of the dead
or 13th warrior same thing but the book
eaters of the dead
remember the vandal yeah they were like
it should have left them like that
a lot of you could see a lot of people
said that these kind of look like orcs
or
or they kind of look like the mole
people from that movie from the 50s
well they don't look like that but it
was like the same kind of concept yeah
because the mole people were
people too but they evolved to be like
moles because they lived underground
yeah i didn't really see the orcs things
to me
i thought they were more like gollum
they're a bunch of bunch of ghosts yeah
i've seen people
comparing them too yeah grandpa's hammer
says there were lava tube caves in
southeast oregon when i lived there in
the 90s
people would explore but i knew that's
where the blind albino cannibals lived
i'm still alive
because i do better yeah
yeah so uh so yeah this came out in 2005
it was directed by neil marshall
now obviously he had done we did a movie
retrospective a long time ago on dog
soldiers which again if you haven't seen
that
is a really really good uh werewolf
movie
and you know british army versus
werewolves it's awesome
and that came out i think in 2002 right
so and that did pretty well
uh so they you know had him do another
movie and this one
originally i think that it was supposed
to be this was kind of like an alien
situation where
it was supposed to be or they kind of
wrote a thing where it was like a mixed
cast or they didn't really care we just
needed a bunch of people to go to the
cave and get eaten
um but then he decided to toy with the
id's like oh kind of like the thing was
all
male cast we wanted to see one that was
like an all-female cash because you
don't see that uh much in these types of
movies
so and i think it worked really well in
this situation so these the six women
they're kind of like you're kind of like
extreme kind of you know people they're
all
into like caving and mountain climbing
and all that kind of crap they're cute
yeah a bunch of cute uh british british
and irish uh girls yeah irish girl with
cute
spiky hair yeah yeah she gets killed
well they're pretty they all get killed
yeah spoilers
i mean pretty much yeah so oh i was
going to say what i was going to say
before you
broke in i was going to say the version
the version that's on amazon prime
has the u.s ending uh which some people
like that better
they're they're not different it's just
that the uk one has another scene
after that like the us one seems to end
kind of abruptly
uh the uk one has another scene which
like makes the movie bleaker
um but they but u.s audiences you know
you know how u.s audience
we wanted a hippie ending or at least
one that was more ambiguous so it's like
okay so they chopped off like the last
few minutes
but um you know but famously there's and
even if you look at the wikipedia page
it tells you it's like this is the us
version and this is uk version
they're same up to a point there's just
a scene that's chopped off on the us one
so uh so sarah is this woman
and they're at the beginning they're
like white water rafting right like her
and uh juno who's her kind of best
friend and then one of the other chicks
and they're doing that and then you so
it's established
pretty early that like sarah and her she
has a husband named paul
and a daughter named jessie jessica and
um
but you know pretty much from the outset
like and if you've seen this movie
before like i said we're probably going
to spoil it because like you know
it's 2006 or 2005 rather and i feel like
a lot of people have seen this one
because it's kind of like
a horror classic from that era so
uh so you can kind of see that sarah and
her husband are kind of like you know
maybe a little distant but then like
there seems to be something going on
between the husband and juno which you
find out later on was was the case
so then like only about three or four
minutes into the movie
um the husband and daughter are horribly
horribly killed in this horrible uh
car accident and then sarah of course is
like she's the only one that survives
she freaks out so then like they jump
ahead a year
and juno her best friend who is also
[ __ ] her husband
uh but sarah doesn't know that yet
decides we have to do this big
trip uh to the appalachian mountains but
it's supposed to be north carolina
although most of the exteriors i think
were shot in scotland and other places
in england the entire cave system where
most of the movie takes place
that is all a set that was built at
pinewood studios
which is you know you you can see why
it's like they don't want to film in
real caves because it's like you don't
yeah that would be
a nightmare and it would be super
dangerous so they wanted to build
something during specifications
but you totally cannot tell i mean i
i thought about it and then i was like
well that can't be a real cave system
because like why would you do that but
like to these poor women but um even
seeing even knowing that it's like fake
it's still
it's just it's mind-blowing how like how
what a good job they did on that
that they just built that on a set that
that blows my mind if you go down into
one of one of those caves
you get what you deserve i had a mercy
for i got enough sympathy for you
it's like these dudes to hang off the
side of the buildings and take a selfie
you know what i mean because they're
hanging off the sides of a damn pole the
building they fall
i don't give a [ __ ] you're the one
that's hanging outside well that's what
i mean that's that's just a darwin award
yeah you start climbing mountains and
[ __ ] you get what you deserve
if you go into those caves you get what
you deserve don't go into the goddamn
cave well and especially
that's dumb to go in there i mean and i
don't i don't mind caves as a rule but
um because i went down in some in whales
and stuff but i'm not going to like some
uncharted ones i'm not going to ones
where you're going to like crawl through
crap i'm not talking about just going in
a damn cave or mom told me to crawl into
this little crowd
no thank you no thank you and i'm not
even particularly claustrophobic
if you're claustrophobic i would not
recommend this movie by any stretch of
these imaginations with you if you gotta
dab crawl down with the little cracks
and can i can i tell you that the first
time that i saw this movie
i was on an airplane i was on an
airplane i was flying either to
i was flying to the uk uh back in 2005
or 2006.
and so you know it's the middle of the
night because i always took like the
overnight flight
it's the middle of the night we're
flying over the atlantic so it's dark in
the plane i can't sleep on planes
because they're because i hate them
and uh i decide unwisely to watch the
descent for the first time and this
movie
stressed me out can you imagine watching
this in a [ __ ]
airplane when you hate flying i was so
[ __ ] stressed out
i'm fascinated by that underground stuff
we've talked about it before but i'm
smart enough to be terrified and i
wouldn't
go down in there like i've been in
carlsbad caverns i've been in a couple
caves there's one outside clarksville
right outside fort campbell me and
torres went into one
but not deep 100 meters we could see the
entrance
you know and it was just an old mine
that's the kind of stuff that i like but
um
man i've heard stories of people that
have gone on these expeditions and
been 30 miles down into there they're in
there for weeks sometimes
and what's weird is that a lot of guys
have been in there before them it's like
a whole scene
you know what i mean well yeah so and
then they kind of go into that a little
bit in this movie
so they kind of know where they're going
but i've heard descriptions of stuff
that's underneath there
that i didn't want to see like [ __ ] like
sorry the neighbors
yeah they've been doing uh guys have
edging found
passages that end in a cliff and then
they shine a light in every direction
they can't see the bottom
or the top then they throw a line out
and find out that there's like
60 stories and that's how much the of
line that they had and it never hit the
bottom
yeah all right [ __ ] no uh they've got
they found they found underneath their
underwater lakes they were big enough
you could put the
damn queen mary on them and sail it
around
in other words an underground ocean nah
no thanks
[Laughter]
which means if it's that big then there
might be islands out there
in an underground ocean there could be
like more locks you have no idea what's
alive
in there well that's what i'm saying
that's why to me the the cave people
that are like down in there that's like
totally plausible
yeah that's the place that's possible
they'll say that there's certain places
in those caves like that one that had
the damn drop
yeah there was constant rain coming from
the ceiling
okay from somewhere but it was would
have been like a like a light drizzle
rain
yeah and then there was like a 30 mile
an hour 40 mile an hour wind blowing
through us there's ventilation
in there there's a whole ecosystem
there's fresh water
there's there's living animals have made
their way
in there over the millennium who knows
what is [ __ ]
still alive well it's just it's kind of
like the bottom of the ocean like nobody
really knows what the hell is farting
around down there
you know there's fish in there uh
somebody claims to have saw
seen tracks of a two-legged lizard that
would have been about a foot tall
like the size of a dam like a sleazy
chicken no like a chick
like a baby sleeve chicken with a lizard
with a chicken with a damn
tail they said it had a tail i don't
know if that's a rumor
because you could lie about anything and
it might be believable but evidently
those are the kind of
rumors kind of stories that people want
to know
okay these places where only a few
people have ever been there
yeah you know nah no thanks i'm not
going away
and that's okay so this kind that kind
of factors into this story too because
so they're supposed to be doing this big
trip because like i said sarah their
friend
uh you know lost her entire family in a
horrible accident she's still not really
over it because it's only been a year
so juno decides um you know and she's
probably feeling guilty too about the
whole [ __ ] her husband thing which
like i said doesn't you don't find that
out till the end
but um well i mean it's foreshadowed at
the beginning it's kind of like
suggested but so she's like okay we're
gonna arrange this big trip so like i
said it's supposed to be
uh in the appalachians it's supposed to
be in north carolina even though they
shop mostly in scotland
uh or at least the exteriors so there's
six of them they all kind of like
there's you know some establishing [ __ ]
at the beginning where it's like that
all the characters are kind of
introduced
and then they go out down into this uh
cave now
what everybody but juno uh doesn't know
is that this is not the cave system that
they thought that they were going to
and in fact it's just kind of like when
you know when you do anything
that's like dangerous like this so when
you go like caving if you're doing like
extreme caving or whatever
you're supposed to file quote-unquote a
flight plan just like you would if
you're flying or doing anything
dangerous so in case you get in trouble
uh
people know where your dumb ass is so
they can come and help you
so apparently one of the other since
they thought they were going to borum
caves
which is kind of a more well-traveled uh
mapped cave system
they thought they were going there so
one of the other women has you know
filed a flight plan for there
now what juno did not tell them though
was that she
actually had found this other supposedly
uncharted cave system
and has led them there instead while
kind of letting them believe
that this is borum caves which some of
the women were like well it seems kind
of touristy like so many people bought
but so juno is kind of like oh well
we're more extreme and we wanted to do
this so we could be the first ones to go
through here it'll be a big deal we can
name it and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so they actually don't find this out
until
uh later on when there's like a cave in
and then they become trapped in there
and then they're just kind of like hey
where's the guidebook or like the map
for the borum caves because that's where
they think they are
then juno is like oh i forgot to tell
you guys this is a totally different
cave system and no one's been in here
and there's no maps of it so
sorry they're in there laughing about
chicken lizards
chicken lizards lizards are chickens
they are yeah and chickens are lizards
yeah they're
they're they're yard lizards yeah
blizzards
yeah delicious yards they're all over
they're all
they're all over mississippi louisiana
and alabama
look at them yet now yard lizards it's
like tree rats
yeah tree rats and squirrels tree rats
yeah
no no shade about rats or squirrels i
guess they eat
them both yeah saw a little chinese kid
holding a rat like
that was they were gonna eat that well
like i said people eat squirrels it's
not really that different
i mean you know i guess we're gross like
rats who the plague and everything like
that but you know
i i you know i wouldn't eat rats i think
rats are cute actually
but you know i don't i'm not grossed out
by red chicken lizards
chicken lizards yeah birds are dinosaurs
so that means chickens are lizards
yeah technically yeah
well yeah just look at their feet yeah
so yeah so
so it's bad enough they go down in this
[ __ ] cave have to contend with like i
said that horrifying scene at the
beginning where there's crawling through
this little bitty
shaft like you know then they all get
through it but then like sarah gets
stuck
and she's like wigging out and even at
that scene which is like pretty
like uh pretty early in the movie tom's
sitting there going
he's like yeah no i don't like this you
know what i mean it's because it's that
and i like i said i'm not even
claustrophobic but
that kind of [ __ ] that would probably
bother me it would bother me
like because you if you couldn't move
your arms and you couldn't turn around
yeah and you could you can't stand him
go [ __ ] it i'm done with this i'm out of
here you can't
you can't get out that's why i'm i'm too
smart for that i'm not going down in a
cave no thanks
i let those psychos do that we'll see
and the shitty thing too
is that this whole time like because
before that happened
like the women thought that they were in
a pretty well-traveled cave system so
they thought oh even if we get in
trouble everyone knows where we
are and it's like people have done this
before and blah blah blah they don't
find out until after that
that um that actually this is not a
well-traveled cave
documentary made that they were down and
explore in one of those damn caves
and um this is on it was on
probably like nature channel or
something and they were down in their
miles in the damn cave and they were
going
down things and down rocks and they
ended up in an open area and they go oh
look and they shine a light and there's
a skeleton of a damn house cat
no no and they go he must have wandered
in here with night and didn't know he
was in a cave
oh imagine that poor kitty cat down in
there and
what does it say about me that i'm more
upset about that than like a dude
because
dick cat doesn't know any better dude
it's all like i'm so extreme i'm going
down the cave i'm like yeah
and you know he was uh he was a mile or
so from the entrance
uh imagine that just sit laying there
and he was probably there going yeah
can't get out of here like beijing does
in the middle of the night
crying to her little babies i don't
think i see [ __ ] like that i'm going
no no no yeah i don't believe i don't
blame him yeah
but uh yeah that's so that's the other
kind of thing so i like that this movie
it goes like almost because it's not
that long it's not 99 minutes i think
this movie is
so it goes like almost halfway through
before they even introduce the monsters
i think there's a couple times when you
can just barely see them in the
background because i think there's one
shot
like pretty early on when they first get
to that cavern you know that they have
to like string the line across because
that big chasm
i think there's one wide shot where you
can just see
like a little like one of the monsters
like in silhouette like way over here in
the corner
um but before like it takes a long time
before they introduce the monsters
and i think i don't see a lot of
criticism of this movie but one of the
main criticisms is that it didn't need
the monsters because the claustrophobia
and the cave
[ __ ] was like scary enough on its own um
but in a way like i don't know i think
that makes this movie better like i saw
another reviewer that said they liked it
because it was like compound horror
because it's like bad enough that you
know
there they figure out that they're like
lost in this [ __ ] cave
they're not in the cave they thought
they were they don't know the way out
no one is no one knows where they are so
no one can come help them if they get
into trouble
so it's like all that horrible [ __ ]
happens you know there's a little
cave-in and all this other stuff
and then on top of that uh then oh by
the way
also there are monsters that will eat
you
uh and also there's a thing too where
sarah is having
they don't really believe her at first
when she because she's the first one
that sees one of the monsters she just
like sees them like drinking some water
or something
like from far away and no one believes
her at first because she's
they've kind of established up to now
that she's doesn't really have all her
marbles together lit yet like i said
because like her whole family got killed
like a year before so it's like you know
she gets
kind of when they first go into the cave
like she gets swarmed by bats and she
like wigs out about that and all the
other women are like maybe she's really
not ready for this like maybe this was a
bad idea
and she's like no no i'm fine but then
like as it goes on she keeps like
hearing her daughter giggling
like in the back so she's having like
auditory hallucinations
and they and they kind of establish too
that sometimes you know people that go
caving uh you know get disoriented or
they'll have like visual or auditory
hallucinations and things like that
so i like that they kind of left it
ambiguous
at first like was she really seeing what
you thought she was seeing because like
i said the women didn't
believe it at first because there are
some people uh
that subscribed to the theory
that the monsters weren't really real
that sarah was just imagining them and
that she was the one that killed all her
friend like she just wigged out and
killed all her friends
um you know i mean i don't think i buy
that but i could see how you could read
it that way
if you wanted to you know but because
they do kind of set up that she's not
like real in her right mind and [ __ ]
so yeah so so they have all this
horrible [ __ ] happens like holly the
irish girl like she falls down a shaft
uh and breaks her leg so which is the
the gore in this is like pretty good
it's like pretty gruesome like
especially that one with her [ __ ]
bones sticking out and they gotta like
yank the leg back and like put a splint
on it
it is yeah it's like she's just like oh
[ __ ] and so uh so yes and then they have
to kind of carry her
around so they had all that bad [ __ ]
happen they don't know where they're
going
and then you know the monsters start
attacking and start eating them
and then so and then they get separated
at some point
because i think they're like in one big
thing and there's like a bunch i think
they call them um
in the i don't think they ever call them
this in the movie but i think the the
crew and everything when they were
working on the movie they called the
monsters the crawlers
because they could crawl on the walls
and stuff which they would like i said
if they'd involved in that environment
so so a little women a couple of them
get eaten and then they all get
separated
and then like you know so they start
getting kind of eaten and [ __ ]
and then there's one point where juno
uh whose fault all of this is i will say
um
because she was the one that was like
hey i'm gonna lead him down to this
[ __ ]
random ass cave system that nobody knows
because she just wanted to be a badass i
guess
so she like kills one of the creatures
and then here's something behind her and
whips around with her [ __ ]
axe or whatever or her pickaxe and kills
one of the other women beth
like accidentally um but then she won't
she won't like she leaves the woman
there like the woman's not dead
and the woman's like don't leave me
don't leave but i think she wanted her
to kill her because it's like i'd rather
be i'd rather you kill me than like be
eaten alive because that would suck a
lot
but um but juno doesn't do that so she
like takes off
and then so as that goes on like every
pretty much everybody gets picked off
you know there's all this horrifying
[ __ ] happening and then
uh sarah the main character she kills
some of the
things but then she finds out she
because she finds beth and she's still
alive and beth says hey um
one juno killed me and two jano is also
[ __ ] your husband
so sorry to be the one to tell you that
um
but don't try so don't trust her so
uh so then she like mercy kills her
and uh so then she ends up when she
finds juno again
who do these two are like the last two
standing i love that they
you know she just kind of shows her like
this whole there's a whole thing with
like a necklace and
all this other stuff that kind of
conveys that information
and then she doesn't kill juno outright
but she basically takes an axe to her
leg and it's like
good luck [ __ ] bye and then like she
leaves her there for the [ __ ]
uh crawlers now so like i said there's
kind of a thing ooh
okay weird it's oh it's updated it's
updating
well it crashed before and then i was
trying to restart it but it wouldn't
come back up
maybe it'll do it now i don't know we'll
see what it'll hopefully i don't have
the sound on it i know it's like oh
everybody's face went blue
but so the weird thing is that okay so
the u.s
ending there's an ending where she
finally she fights
through and she gets um and she gets out
at the end like she crawls out like over
all these bones and everything
and then she gets back in her car and
you know goes tear ass and down the road
and then she pulls over and she's like
crying and freaking out and then she
turns and sees
presumably like juno's ghost or she's
seeing a hallucination ever
and then the us version just abruptly
ends right there like after she sees
the ghost which is weird but okay
the uk version has goes on for longer
the uk version after that scene she
actually uh sarah wakes up in the
still in the cave so that whole thing
with her escaping
and getting in the truck and driving
away and all that that was a
hallucination
um so the british version ends with her
still being stuck in the cave and not
being able to get out
and they pull back and there's just like
crawlers everywhere so you're just like
and she's just having that hallucination
again about her daughter like with the
birthday cake that you've seen like a
bunch of times in the movie thus far
so they're pretty much just saying you
know she
she's not gonna make it out you know and
that's like her last thought is of her
dead daughter uh you know before the
walker's coming or the crawlers would
rather come and eat her
so which in a way it's a bleaker ending
but i like that ending better
um because the us one seems like a
little more abrupt
now interestingly they made a sequel to
this which i saw
i remember it being okay but i don't
really remember all that much about it
i think the the sequel um
presumes that sarah got out so it went
more with the us
version than the uk verse because the uk
version i mean they pretty much imply
that she
that she died that everybody died um
which
you know so so i don't know i don't get
that but like i said i don't
i don't remember hardly anything about
the sequel but i do remember that it
carried on from like the ending of the
us version and not the uk version
you know what i mean yeah but um yeah so
i mean i can see easily see why
this movie is considered like one of the
best horror movies
you know of this decade of you know the
2000 to the 2010s or even like the 21st
century as a whole
it's just a really good it's a simple
premise
um it doesn't really let up um you know
it starts slightly slow
like with well after the car accident
because that happens like pretty quick
but then it's just there's a little bit
of character development you know in a
cabin and whatnot
but then once they get into the caves
it's pretty much like one shitty thing
happening after another and it's just
one thing compounds on the other and
just gets worse and worse
and um just the way it's shot i've heard
that it's better because like i said the
first time i saw it was in a plane which
again was not the ideal situation
because i'm stressed out on planes
enough as it is and i really didn't need
the extra stress of like watching a
movie like this
but i've heard that seeing this in the
theater is really fantastic because like
the theater is just like completely dark
and a lot of times the screen is
completely dark and it's only lit by
like a flare or something like that so
you're essentially seeing the same
things that the character would see if
you were in the cave with them
so they said it's a lot more stressful
when you see it in the theater because
you're
you're kind of put in the same place as
like the protagonist so it's like super
super claustrophobic
watch this movie again it actually kind
of reminded me a lot of underwater
i thought you might say that because i
kind of picked up on that
uh as well yeah because it's i like it
underwater yeah
it's any kind of thing that's just like
a bunch of people and
they're in like a really bad situation
like a really claustrophobic situation
like in underwater they were you know
just underwater obviously and they were
trying to get to this other thing and
you know there were monsters so it's
kind of like a similar premise now that
you think about it
um you know so because it's like they
had all this shitty stuff that was
happening like
you know nature wise but then they were
like monsters i gotta say though i think
i liked underwater better i like this
movie
i do i like to i think i like underwater
a little bit better underwater was a
very underrated movie
yeah oh yeah yeah if you like this one
see underwater
yeah like i said it's a similar premise
it's you know it's a different it's it's
a really like
inhospitable environment imagine if
ridley scott was making this movie in
the in the in the world of blade runner
but it was like underneath the water
blade runner and aliens yeah and it's
damn underneath the water in an
underwater [ __ ] mining station
with young people working in there it
was good i liked it
yeah so it was very similar to this and
it was it had guys and girls in it
yeah which like i said i think that was
the original intention for this one but
then they just decided to go with all
women because you just didn't see that
much
um and they thought it would give it
like a little bit of a different dynamic
but you know in
in the main it doesn't matter all that
much i don't think but it's just because
it's just basically like
you know a group of people and they're
in this really bad situation that just
keeps getting worse and worse and then
oh by the way there are monsters
and like i said it's just i like it
because it just keeps ramping [ __ ] up
and part two is out it's been out i'd
like to see part two i haven't seen it
part two came out like a long time i
don't remember i remember it being all
right
i know a lot of people really hated it
um
because like i said it was predicated on
the us version where
sarah actually did get out but in the uk
version she didn't get out uh everybody
died
so so i think that was kind of a thing i
remember watching it i think it was on
el rey or something like a few years ago
and i remember it being like okay
i remember like not loving it and not
hating it i was just kind of like
mediocre about it
but i can't tell you a single thing that
happens in it though
in the second one you're saying what if
you know
that who was at the saying that to me
pat says uh well who was it no it's dom
the bomb says ridley scott how about
john carpenter talking no that felt like
a ridley scott movie to me
it did actually see yeah this this movie
seemed more similar to a ridley scott
movie than uh or
than a john carpenter movie to me yeah
well no he was talking about uh
he was talking about underwater
underwater felt like a ridley scott
movie to me well yeah
yeah well this is this one too well yeah
that's what i mean if i had to say
yeah i mean not carpenter yeah carpenter
kind of had kind of a lightheartedness
unrealistic feel to it that was good
these are kind of a little bit more
realistic more realism
yeah i mean this one to be honest with
you
up until where the cave people appear
it's like completely realistic it's all
[ __ ] that could go
bro and and the interesting thing too is
that all of these women are very
experienced
cavers so they're not just complete
idiots that just blundered into the
situation
um you know they have all the right
equipment they have the know-how they've
done this before
so they don't do anything like intensely
stupid
uh really the only person that put them
in the situation like i said is the
character of juno because she led them
down this cave system
you know not telling them that it wasn't
the cave system they were supposed to be
in
so she kind of like [ __ ] everybody and
got everybody killed and even when the
monsters appear
they're organic monsters they're
realistic monsters i mean as
in movie making terms it's like you
could totally this is a totally
plausible
scenario that there's like some kind of
man-like
animal that kind of evolved down there
that's like cannibalistic
that would eat you you know what i mean
so it's not
there's nothing supernatural it's not
crazy or anything like that but yeah and
so i like that
it's like it's almost kind of like an
action movie there is like
character development you know there's
stuff that happens like between some of
the characters but it's kept pretty
minimal
um and most of it is not a lot of it's
not really conveyed through the dialogue
a lot of it's kind of conveyed through
other kind of means
so so i think it's good because there's
not there's dialogue in this but there's
not a [ __ ] ton
yeah you know what i mean so it's it's
more like an action-oriented like moving
from point a to point b like here's this
terrible situation now we got to deal
with this and
all that other kind of stuff so in that
way it's very
straightforward and um you know it's got
really good
considering this cost less than four
million pounds to make
uh and they built a whole entire cave
system which totally looks real
uh also the monster effects are great
though like the monsters look great
um the gore is great there's like some
really gruesome
uh scenes in this the only really the
only criticism of it i have is like
sometimes
occasionally during the kind of like
fight scenes where some of the women are
like fighting the monsters
some of the editing is like a little bit
too quick to like see exactly
like what's going on like who is
fighting who or like what exactly is
happening
but that's like a pretty minor criticism
because i feel like that was kind of
like they sped up the action and then
they're doing little jump cuts to it
it's hard to tell what the [ __ ]
happening sometimes
yeah i mean you know that it's like oh
it's her and she's fighting a monster
but sometimes you're not entirely sure
like who's hitting who
kind of a sign that the stunt work
wasn't all that great wasn't that all
impressive when you first saw it so they
had to speed it up and
do a bunch of edits although i do kind
of feel like the 2000s were like a big
that was like a big quit editing quick
editing type of [ __ ]
now i'm gonna say like neil marshall
like i said he had done dog soldiers
like i think two or three years before
this
and i don't know which movie i like but
i don't know they're kind of different
i mean i love dog soldiers because
that's like such a good and i love the
werewolves in that and like the
characters and that are so
awesome but it's like this one is really
good too and like i said even though
even if you're not claustrophobic i mean
you might be like after you watch this
[ __ ] movie because
just some other [ __ ] that happens in it
i was more scared like the
claustrophobia [ __ ] where she gets like
stuck in that in that like tunnel or
whatever
that like is pretty freaky but i think
the part that scared me more
was when they were trying to get a line
over that big chasm
because i'm more way more scared of
heights than i'm like i'm
like way more scared of heights and i'm
like you know claustrophobia
so the fact when that when that first
girl had to go across and put like all
the anchors like into the rock so she
could make
you know the the line so all the other
women could get across this big huge
[ __ ] chasm
it's like that stressed me out like more
than the getting the stuff so
this has something for everybody's
phobias i guess
i see the only thing they could have
added was if somebody just got like fell
in a thing and got
covered with spiders or something they
didn't do that but it's like
so it had some height [ __ ] in it too and
that kind of like freaked me out also
mike barrett says leviathan is alien
underwater pretty much a ripoff yeah
i remember and i think leviathan might
be on amazon prime too
um i don't think i've ever seen it i saw
it in the theater it's pretty good is
that the one with the uh
the russian experiment that gets out and
it's like uh the monster's eating
all the guys got the different from got
the dude from robocop
i think so yeah yeah yeah i have seen it
yeah yeah it's pretty good is that right
i remember seeing it in the theater
being like yeah that was pretty good but
yeah it's okay because i remember like i
was flipping through amazon prime the
other day and i said no leviathan
i probably haven't seen it yet all right
so uh
is that all we have to say about this
guy here is going to be [ __ ] us up
how i mean how much edge does he have to
edge he's cutting his whole damn forest
down
do you know what i mean i don't
understand like sometimes the dude like
i'm glad he's keeping his
like yard looking nice and everything
like that but it's like his yard is not
that big i don't understand why it takes
that [ __ ] long
i just i really don't he likes his work
maybe he's just standing there going ah
i just like to make noise trying to find
but yeah so uh all right so anyway
it's tuesday which means that tomorrow
is wednesday which means that tomorrow
night is the side track show yeah i need
to get ready so prepare your liver
yes yeah it's my job to get drunk
we don't have to i mean you could just
have one you know what i mean it's like
so don't make it seem like last time
that [ __ ] happened i took my clothes off
not all of them yeah maybe one day
you'll get strong enough to shake it off
it'd be like dancing around just dance
around with his little bear butt in the
camera
to get the channel to monetize well it
just it just get a wide angle lens for
this
it's just a video against monetize
stuff like that okay i've only had a
couple i've only had a couple of videos
to monetize and usually it was because
of copyright stuff
like if we showed like part of a music
video or something then
they'll demonetize that but it's like
that's pretty much the only
reason that it's gotten demonetized
nothing we talked about ever got us to
monetize
but uh yes anyway the joys of having
neighbors yeah
they're pretty quiet i mean but yeah he
does like do a lot of yard work and my
office is like
right next to their where their pool
area is so it's like whenever they're
doing yard work it's super loud in here
but yeah so uh tune in tomorrow evening
at 5 p.m eastern for the side track show
who the [ __ ] knows what we'll be talking
about i don't [ __ ] know we'll find
out
we'll all find out together it'll be
super fun but yeah so
have a good rest of your day thanks
everybody for dropping by and hanging
out with us
and we'll see you guys tomorrow bye